hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen in a new
place hopefully this is gonna be my
setup for a long time because moving
sucks today I am watching Evil Dead 2
the only thing that I know about Evil
Dead 2 is that it's like a remake of the
first I guess it's better than the first
and also there is a mounted moose head
that yells and moves around also in the
vein of mounted heads I had an
incredible prop for this flippin video
that was so excited about but I need Ike
for it and there won't be any cats in
this video because they're at another
place because moving with cats is a
nightmare
I have this mounted moose head cat
costume and it would have been so funny
oh what a missed opportunity you guys
Rachel and I bought this together I'm
pretty sure at a thrift store around our
first Halloween in Chicago anyway now
that that'll happen
um hooray Evil Dead 2 I'm so excited
Oh Tamara's never seen Tom Toba Fest
holy crap you guys it is one of my
favorites
I wouldn't categorize it as a horror
movie what do you put this under I don't
know funny slasher so if you skip to the
first 10 minutes of the second one then
you could watch it as if it were like a
number 2 to the first which is weird so
it starts off with Ash and his
girlfriend Linda and then none of the
other friends are there they're just
going up to this cabin for a romantic
retreat and he gives her the necklace
okay Linda is possessed and she bites
Ash's hand and won't let go pretty rude
and Ash's super Jim Carrey esque in this
whole portion and the whole movie he's
looking looks like Jim Carrey like a lot
like a lot a lot is that thing that that
people compared into because he's very
like subdued Jim Carrey
so then ash chainsaws Linda's head off
which true love
and then he goes back to the house and
trades the chainsaw for a single bullet
gun which I mean does that make sense to
you because it doesn't make sense to me
because you know that you have to take
off all of their limbs in their head and
why you're just gonna shoot at him one
bullet at a time you if they're like
reload maybe it's two bullets I don't
know I don't want guns work then there's
this really cool and disturbing scene
where Linda comes out of her grave and
she's like dancing around with like a
really badly decomposed body and it's
gross and cool and so unsettling like
she's just so creepy and then she like
disappears behind some trees then his
hand just gets possessed you bastards
give me back my hand give me back my
hand and it's touching and said you can
keep my girlfriend just give me my hands
back Oh hair flip I breathe so it's like
hair clumps clump
well Club what's rude comments on the
last video and someone was like if she
ever gonna stop hair flipping or is that
just gonna be a permanent thing yeah I
don't know that it's a permanent thing
but also I love love meaning that I hate
that people were so mad that I brought
up the tree rape as a negative thing in
the last video this is literally a video
of me reacting to a movie I saw and I
saw tree rape someone was like oh we get
it you don't like tree rape why don't
you just watch Disney and Pixar for the
rest of your life like that's so stupid
no something I love about this version
of the movie versus the first movies
version of the movie is the addition of
the people who own the cabin and the
people who like discovered the Book of
the Dead the dad owns the cabin he's
supposed to be at the cabin and the
daughter is trying to get back to him
with her boyfriend then you meet these
two super redneck characters who are
like we'll take if you pay us and they
don't have that accent that was totally
mean don't cut back to ash who has cut
his hand off and who was weirdly calm
about getting his end up like he
apparently doesn't feel any pain he
literally go sleep
like he touches his nub which would be
incredibly painful then the hand escapes
from the bucket and he shoots it through
a wall and like gallons and gallons and
hundreds of thousands of gallons of
blood just spill out of it which is why
it was visually very entertaining but
what the fuck what fuck what the fuck
but what the oh then the mounted deer
head because I'm really sad he's not
here but you lucked out on escaping your
costume here so good for you but I'm
actually I'm happy for him
so the moose said which do we even need
to talk about it it's great should I
skip over it like I should have skipped
over the tree rape no I'm gonna talk
about it right it's crazy the lamps and
the books and everything they're just
like laughing like it's mickey's fun
house and then ash starts laughing and
he's like flipping nuts and it's a solid
minute of insane laughing and it fits
the movie very well and is very
entertaining and I'm all about it so the
rednecks and the owners of the cabin get
there and knock ash out because I think
that he killed their parents then they
knock him into the cellar and listen to
the recording from the dad and realized
that he didn't kill the parents um and
that their mother is buried in the
cellar then you just hear this crazy
voice go there's someone in my fruit
cellar ah so they get ash out of the
cellar and I'm watching this movie with
closed captions on and it just goes
demon : hey yeah which I didn't hear the
mom demon say hi ah but it was a funny
nonetheless this whole sequence and like
I mean the whole movie is so cheesy
and he's that because I grew up with
movies that weren't as cheesy or is it
because they recognize the cheesiness of
the first and just like fucking went
with it I don't know I don't know but I
really love it it's very compelling the
cinematography is super compelling and
interesting and at times it feels really
sloppy but sloppy in like a way that's
like well it's cool
look like that cool artist in high
school who like never took shower be
like man he's cool versus like sloppy
like like I am with like not putting
shit away like it's in artistic way
so then Annie's father's soul talks to
them and tells them to use the new pages
they found to get the demons away a so
then the redneck girl Bobby Joe gets
spooked runs out into the forest and I
thought there was going to be another
tree rape scene but it wasn't so I'm
glad honestly I can't think of one
instance where tree rape needs to be in
a movie like weird like has to be in a
movie to tell the story I just can't
think of one instance so then the
redneck girlfriends redneck boyfriend is
like where's Bobby Jo and there he's
like you guys have to come help me find
it and she's like ash Annie come on
they're like no he's like yes and he
throws the new pages it's gonna save
them down to the cellar with the crazy
fruit seller mom ash gets turned into
this terrifying demon the most
terrifying of all the demons and the
most convincing looking as well and then
the redneck boyfriend who I don't I
never learned his name but he gets
stabbed in the stomach by Annie it's a
mess it's just a jock it's a mess then
demon ash sees the pendant that he gave
Linda in the beginning and it breaks him
free of his demonic gaze and this is the
second time that he's become not a demon
after being a demon and it just is he
invincible is he the only one who can
break free from being a demon so they
have to go into the cellar to get the
pages and ash makes his head into a
chainsaw arm and it's so flippin also if
you guys haven't watched Jim's awesome
build for the chainsaw arm prop it is
flippin awesome also I just really like
the intro that he does it's very like it
in stylized for Evil Dead it's so cool
definitely watch it definitely watch it
so ash gets the pages from the basement
but then the mom attacks them and she is
terrifying she looks like a bloater from
The Last of Us have you played that game
really terrifying zombie characters the
bloaters that's what she looks like
then he chops her up and he does some
amazing gun moves swallow this and they
have a great moment so she gets hurt but
she has to say the passage to open up
this riff to get the evil tree all of
these demons out there not just
treatments they just there are trees
involved she's like trying to say it but
she's so hurt and it's like girls spin
out and she finally she opens the Rif
rift ripped or riff the riff in time the
rift in time rift I think it's ripped
Club then ash in his terrible gray hair
streak are pulled through and of course
he ends up being the savior who saves
the ancient people from the monster
mentioned at the beginning of the film I
didn't mention this but there was a
savior mentioned beautiful something
that I thought that was really weird
about this part though was that they got
there and he did not want to be the
savior and he realized he was in this
past and there were ancient demons and
and and she was like so distressed about
it and I feel like I don't know I can't
think of an example but I feel like I've
seen similar things before but they're
like okay with their newfound heroism
and they're like oh yeah cool on this
hero in this like ancient placement he
was like super not into it and it was
unsettling I feel like since starting
Tamra's never seen it's harder to get
through movies because now it's like a
job oh your life is so hard
mm-hmm you know what I mean though like
it's just it it it's kind of hard to get
through it for some reason now but this
one was like so easy to get through I
was super into it it split plate blip
blip blip it's pretty split though
between what people prefer the second or
the third I don't know if I've heard
anyone say that the first is their
favorite um tree rape but but if it is
cool that's awesome but yeah I'm
interested to see if 2 or 3 is gonna be
my jam
as I I enjoyed one and two for sure so
we will see anyways guys next video Ike
will be back so don't worry about that I
might I might bring this back though
just you can see a minute he's had it
too easy for too long
he needs a challenge in his life and you
got any guys any guys ways welcome
sentences are hard anyways guys welcome
to the new place next video this will be
organized premium bananas might be gone
maybe not maybe premium bananas will
just stay here as a staple in my life I
love bananas only if they're premium
[Music]
you